in the last video we talked about
ionization energy or the energy required
to remove an electron and we saw the
general trend in the periodic table that
you know when you're in the bottom
left-hand side close to cesium cesium
really wants to give up electrons it's a
big atom it only has one extra electron
and it's six shell it can just give it
up and then it'll have five complete
shells so it really wants to give it
away so it requires very little energy
to ionize on their complete other side
of the spectrum helium helium requires a
lot of energy to ionize it's very happy
it has a full shell at the first shell
it's a very small atom the electrons are
very close to the protons so the Coulomb
force is super duper duper strong so it
takes a lot of energy to remove that
increment electron we learned that and
the one thing I want to cover before
moving on to other types of trends or
properties amongst the different atoms
is the idea of a second ionization
energy second ionization second
ionization energy now I do this because
sometimes it's covered on some chemistry
exams or some chemistry standardized
tests and it's just the idea the
ionization energy is the energy required
to remove the first electron to go from
a neutral state to take you popping one
off one electron off of it the second
ionization energy is then the energy
required to remove the very next
electron and the reason why this is
interesting is sometimes you'll say okay
you know with what elements have a very
high second ionization energy and your
your temptation would be okay high
ionization energy that also probably
means high second ionization energy and
that might be true for example neon has
a very high ionization energy really
wants to keep that tenth electron
because it fills out the the second
shell and then of course even at if you
were able to remove that electron to
remove the the ninth electron when you
know now it's configuration looks a lot
like fluorine that's still very
difficult so you'd say it's second
ionization energy is still very high but
if you think about it the elements with
the second the elements with the highest
second ionization energy
are going to be some of the elements
with the lowest ionization energy so
think about it and they might be kind of
confusing and let me say lithium lithium
for example very low ionization energies
got that little extra electron it just
wants to give it away but once it gives
it away it's in a very stable situation
then its electron configuration looks
like helium so to remove that second
electron is super duper duper difficult
so lithium has a very high second
ionization energy and so you might run
into a question where they're like you
know what which of these elements has
the biggest difference between their
their ionization energy and their second
ionization energy or their second
ionization energy is higher than their
ionization energy and lithium or
anything in Group one that would be true
because as soon as you remove one
electron its electron configuration
becomes super stable so removing that
second one is super duper difficult and
you also see this in this chart this is
of course the first ionization energies
but let's say the case with lithium you
remove that electron it was very easy
you only needed five electron volts to
do it but then your configuration looks
a lot like helium so that second
ionization energy is going to look a lot
like helium's first ionization energy
anyway don't want to confuse you too
much but that's an interesting point
that might pop up every now and then now
another property which is in a lot of
ways in my mind related is the idea of
electro negativity electro negativity
concept came up with by Linus Pauling I
always remember him is he was convinced
that vitamin E a famous chemist and you
know but his what I always remember is
that he was famous for being convinced
that vitamin C was kind of the key to
living forever and he would take huge
doses of vitamin C I should probably
read up on that again I don't want to
spread lies about Linus Pauling but I
remember reading that when I was in high
school but anyway he came up with the
idea of electronegativity and the idea
is that the one two atoms form covalent
bonds and I haven't cover haven't taught
you what a covalent bond is so and I was
planning on doing that in in a couple of
videos from now covalent bond but the
idea of a covalent bond is really just
atoms sharing electrons let me draw that
out so if I have oxygen oxygen looks
something
like this I could draw it like that I
could also draw oxygen like this just
because I'm going to use these extra
electrons to bond and it should take
Elektra oxygen like that you you add it
to two hydrogen's hydrogen has one
electron what's going to happen well you
might not know yet if you haven't seen a
covalent bond but the atoms will
actually share electrons so this oxygen
you put it in the center you have these
over here let me draw it like that so
the oxygen I'll do it in green the
electrons from oxygen I'll do in green
and then in hydrogen hydrogen well I'll
just do it in this orange color so we
have two of these hydrogen's so one
hydrogen will be there and then the
other hydrogen will be there now what
just happened well if this hydrogen if
this hydrogen can pretend that both of
these electrons it has to kind of share
this green room with the oxygen and the
deal is hey I share the green one and
you know you let me borrow the green
room and I'll let you borrow the orange
one we both can kind of feel like we
have a stable electron configuration
hydrogen feels good because the 1s shell
is completely filled oxygen feels great
because it's its valence shell is
completely filled with eight electrons
you know two of which are barred so it
feels great this is a covalent bond
where where the atoms are sharing
electrons and so this is sometimes will
be drawn like this oxygen those are the
extra electron pairs of oxygen and
they'll just draw a line like that a
line like that and these that line
implicitly is saying look there's two
atoms on either end you know there's the
oxygen atom I'm gonna saw the electron
the oxygen electron there and then you
have the hydrogen electron there and
they're kind of shared these two things
mean the same thing but that but that
line just means a covalent bond now my
whole point behind talking about
covalent bonds a little prematurely so
that I can touch on electronegativity
and the idea that Linus Pauling came up
with is that in these covalent bonds the
sharing is not equal that some of the
elect some of the atoms will hog the
electrons a little more so in this case
oxygen I mean we learn
about oxygen oxygen oxygens way over
here it loves to grab electrons because
it's way you know it's it has a very
high ionization energy it's you know
it's only two away from having an
electron configuration similar to neon
and being super duper happy so oxygen
loves electrons hydrogen's a little bit
here there could gain electron and then
it'll be it'll have a stable 1s orbital
or it can lose an electron and a little
centrally just turn into a positive ion
it can go either way so it's a little
bit more ambivalent about which you know
what what what it does what happens
relative to the electrons but oxygen
really wants the electrons so that it
can get completed
so in this relationship between oxygen
and hydrogen oxygen is more
electronegative it's more
electronegative which means it kind of
hogs the electrons a little bit more so
if you were to draw this this
relationship here it might look
something you know if you were to draw
this this bond and you know this is all
abstract and you know maybe you would
draw it that it would be a little bit
heavier on that side and this is not
really at all a convention but I just
made that up or if you just drew thee
just say the the hydrogen and the oxygen
part of it maybe you know the electrons
spend most of their time around if this
is a probability distribution and less
of their time around hydrogen and that
would be the true that would be true for
the other hydrogen they spend less of
their time around the hydrogen a lot
more of their time around the oxygen the
idea of electronegativity is just that
one atom is going to hog the add of the
electrons more when you form a covalent
bond now if we wanted to figure out the
trend of electronegativity on the
periodic table what do you think is
going to happen which out which elements
are likely to hog electrons well the
ones that love electrons the ones that
it's very hard to take electrons away
from them the ones that are so close to
compose to completing their there
they're a full full eight valence
electrons in their outermost shell so
the most electronegative atoms are going
to be right here they're going to be
they're going to be the halogens
especially the fluorine because the
small ones are going to be they want the
electrons even more cuz they're a small
atom the electrons are going to get
closer to nucleus
and the reason why I'm not talking about
the the noble gases here is because
these actually these don't form covalent
bonds there they're always happy they
don't they just you know there are all
these the inert gases and ER it just
means that they don't do anything
similar word is inertia inertia means
you know the tendency to want to stay at
rest not do anything or stay in motion
but I won't go into that too much but
these are inert they don't do anything
so these guys react they form covalent
bonds up here and when they form
covalent bonds they hog the atoms
likewise when these guys down here form
covalent bonds they're like you know
what you can have the atoms I don't I
don't need them I'm actually happier
without them altogether in fact
sometimes these guys actually just give
away the atom they don't even form a
covalent bond it's called an ionic bond
we'll talk about that in the next video
but you can see the trend is the same as
it is for for for ionization energy
these guys a lot of energy required to
remove an electron and that's because
they love electrons so these guys are
also very electronegative they're going
to hog the electrons in in a covalent
bond these guys very low ionization
energy very easy to take an electron
away from them and that's why they have
very low electronegativity they're very
let their that are very unlikely to hog
an electron in a bond now the other
trend that some people sometimes talk
about is the metallic nature of the
element metallic nature metallic nature
of an element and so you know there's a
lot of things that in my mind kind of
eyes imagine when someone talks about
metallic nature I imagine it should
conduct electricity it should be shiny
it should be malleable and you know I
can kind of bend it without it cracking
that's how I imagine metallic nature but
when people talk about in chemistry
they're really just talking about a
willingness to give away electrons
that's metallic nature and that is you
know that is important if you talk about
something that's going to conduct
electricity or be malleable or have kind
of the you know have this kind of sea of
electrons available that the atoms can
sit in but the same trend which which
atoms are very likely to give away
electrons
well the bottom left right
as you go down the Adam gets bigger so
the electrons are further away from the
nucleus so the the the nuclear force is
or the the Coulomb force is weaker so
those electrons are more weakly bound
and also if you just have one extra
electron here or two extra electrons
there in your outermost shell you're
just like hey let me get rid of them and
then I'll have a complete I'll have a
complete outer shell so these guys want
to give away electrons so they have a
very high metallic nature these guys
want to keep electrons so they have a
lot and they want to take more so they
have a very low metallic nature in fact
these are you know these are completely
nonmetallic in any way and you know
within a and if you were to say within a
group the trend I mean I did the
diagonal but that's in general true is
that the further you go down a group the
rate the size of the atom is increasing
in the outer the outer electrons are
further from the nucleus so the electron
force is going to be weaker or the
Coulomb force is going to be weaker so
you're more likely to give away electron
so you're metallic nature will increase
as you go down and your metallic nature
will increase as you go to the left
because when you only have a couple of
electrons in your outermost shell you
want to give them away so metallic
nature it goes in the opposite direction
goes like that but for the same reason
these guys love to hog electrons these
lot guys love to give them away
right so ionization energy increased to
the top right electronegativity increase
to the top right metallic nature
increase to the bottom left the last
trend we could talk about is just atomic
radius atomic radius and there's a lot
of different ways to actually measure
this and there's no one best way because
obviously it we already talked about it
atom doesn't have a fixed radius so the
electron could show up pretty much
anywhere so you can just kind of do a
hard boundary okay 90% chance of finding
the electron that's your sphere of the
atom or you could say okay if this atom
bonds with another atom what is the what
is half the distance between the two
nucleus is right if you make a bond like
that then you could call the this is the
distance between the two nucleuses and
then you could say the atomic radius is
and so there's a lot of ways but I think
you get the general idea it's just the
size of the atom and you could already
imagine that as you go down any one
group the size of the atom increases
you're adding on more and more energy
levels more and more shells that the
atom is just getting larger and larger
in fact we've used that as an argument
as to why as you go down ionization
energy goes down or electronegativity
goes down so the atoms become larger let
me make it the atoms become larger as
you go down now the one thing that might
be a little unintuitive what happens is
you go to the right you're adding
electrons as you go to the right but
you're also but you're adding them all
in the same shell right so if this is a
nucleus right there and you're in some
shell some orbital shell and obviously
they're not all spheres but let's say in
your sub orbital shell you just keep as
you go to the right in a period you just
keep adding electrons to that shell all
right this is a super gross
oversimplification and as you go to the
right you're also have you have more
protons in the nucleus so this is only
getting more and more positively charged
so what happens is is that these
electrons get pulled inwards they get
pulled inwards so as you move to the
right on the periodic table size
decreases so size decreases size
decreases so the general trend with size
and then you say okay but what about
when you go to the next period you're
adding more you're getting more protons
there won't that decrease you are but at
the same time you're now adding the
electrons in a new shell that's further
from them so it gets larger when you get
to the new when you go to the new period
so electron size as you go down large
and as you go to the left you get larger
so electron size goes from the bottom
right to the top left although in
general the things that are in the in a
in a lower period will have a larger
size than most things in a higher period
regardless of kind of what group it's in
but the general trend would then appear
within a group the more the higher the
number the larger
the atom within a period that the more
protons you have the smaller the atom
anyway hope you found those interesting
in the next few videos we'll start with
bonding